[Musique]
à
en soutien au personnel soignant et à
tous les ambulanciers qui participent à
cette crise comme vous le savez depuis
un certain temps à 20h les gens
applaudissent par la fenêtre et il ya
des départements ont commencé à se
rassembler entre ambulanciers pour faire
un petit peu de bruit à 20 heures à
paris ça se faisait pas donc on a décidé
de commencer à le faire
[Musique]
ça fait très chaud au coeur là une belle
solidarité puis à vraiment on ressent
tout tout l'esprit d'équipé qui a dans
les petites secondes c'est vraiment
extraordinaire et ça va vraiment ça
motive à se lever chaque matin pour
venir combattre cette maladie que
coville devrait vraiment se voit c'est
la première fois que j'assiste à ça
c'est tellement incroyable vraiment
cruel mobilisation
[Musique]
parce qu'ils en font des gens comme nous
on est sur place et aller jusqu'au bout
pour combattre ces dérives
je
[Musique]